so Gerry you make a habit it seems of
making dramatic entrances in Game of
Thrones how likely are we to see you
make another dramatic entrance in season
four let's just say yes I will always
make a dramatic entrance even if it's
not very dramatic I shall try and garner
something from it yes oh I can't say
anything now there's been a lot of drama
obviously in season 3 and what was your
reaction to the red wedding my lord
I knew about it I knew it was gonna
happen
I saw some of the guys the day after
they filmed it and I still cried I was
still really shocked and I apparently I
didn't realize but there's loads of them
reaction videos of people filming people
who I haven't seen any I would love to
but I think if you film me it would have
been the same like oh oh oh stop him
stop here so yeah I was very shocked I
was very shocked but I don't think there
was anyone who wasn't so yeah they put
you off getting married on Game of
Thrones
no I think my character be up for a up
for a fight yeah she wouldn't get killed
she's way to better Susie she-she's see
off that world afraid love if she just
ran for it like ah but no no I I would
might get married on the show here would
be your top guess and who would you
definitely have banned from your wedding
list um I would my top guests would be
Aria of course and I would ban ban
Littlefinger mm-hmm yeah no no no let me
saying if you get rid of anyone on the
show be Littlefinger oh I'm sorry Aidan
it's so creepy
the Aidan's not I mean men either
character character Littlefinger it's
too early you got me to a function yet
another character he's not very nice as
Ramsay snow and we talked about Alfie
and him pickle he's been in lost season
Joey's say drew though now we spoke to
Alfie and to you and Riaan after we
spoke to you lost and both of them said
that Joffrey was much worse and Ramsey
what do you make of that oh I don't know
they're both sick sadistic bastard
aren't they I think we've seen more of
Joffrey like more of ways capable of so
I would probably have to say Joffrey
because we've seen seen his range of
evil whereas they went in going no I
mean yeah what he did to Alfie in season
3 that I then received in a box it's
just I would Jeffrey did probably
whichever would do that yeah I think I
was bad as each other for different
reasons what did you think when you
first got that script where you get that
little present from Ramsay snow um I was
like what wonder if they'll be anything
in the box and there was the props
Department did him proud to say that and
now it's making him he's doing a tour of
the exhibition
[Music]
lots of people ask but was there
anything in the box and lots of people
think maybe there was a joke or
something in the box to try and make us
put it off but no there was an actual
member if you do did you have to contain
yourself when you open it with the first
time no because we'd rehearsed it and so
I knew I knew I knew
yamo they didn't sneak it in between
rehearsal an actual film note no no
there was no prank no it was genuinely a
probably set up and I knew what I was
going to find if you could give her some
advice for future seasons what would you
say to her to do what would I say to her
just keep being badass front foot come
on
yeah I suppose they do little grim I'd
like it to smile more yeah she could go
you're such serious things in there one
time yeah maybe like go to a Kayleigh
Yara you know lighten up have a bond on
that's one second and maybe you could
bring through the Dragons that you
wanted when we spoke last as well why
not get the Dragons involved over Kaylie
you haven't won just you know it's all
right bit of a barbecue made with a
dragon a barbecue now it's all kidding
love it if you could pick one character
on the show to have their own reality TV
show who would it be and why maybe part
of be interesting that we all want to
know what happened in there with the you
know you know we saw a bit of it but
yeah if there was a reality TV show
where we had to follow him everywhere
maybe that'd be interesting this is kind
of it ending Messick what do you think
it involved oh I lost
I'd love it if it was just like him Oh
making the tea having a bit of a tea
loaf you know maybe getting some friends
round and then certainly going for work
I'm necessarily going whoring as a
ringing the door at all when I was about
to happen if you could bring anyone back
to life who's had the chop on the show
he would you bring back Catlin probably
I like her yeah she tried so hard say
Rob doesn't she by threatening the wife
of world affray be isn't care know
exactly exactly
no I bring my Caitlin we've lost our
matriarch he would you like to see on
the Iron Throne
who's your idea or ruler Western Oh so
every time I got asked this and every
time I just think there's something nav
on the Iron Throne do you know what
serious answer probably Tyrion or
Daenerys really I'd say I would love if
it was area or even bran and yam I am I
don't know there's so many great
contenders on there I don't know I'm
really happy to wait and see and really
happy I'll be happy with any of them
Jemma you fit as a star as always thank
you very much very much for speaking to
me
bye everyone
you